[Music]
so here at the Pete holes show we love
video games I love them the staff loves
them and we wanted to find a way to
shine a spotlight on some of our lesser
known favorite video games and uh I
don't know if you know this here at the
pet home show we do have all the
games uh first off what do we have here
we have a Super Mario half Brothers
awkward family
Barbecue it's actually the tension
cooking the hot dogs they've got some
easy games that I like a lot like all
long piece
Tetris they make it for babies but it
makes me feel like a
winner uh Grand Theft Auto Canada sure
you can borrow it that's a fun
one just neighbors helping
neighbors paper boy 2 just a regular
grown mail
carrier he never levels
up too
real not real enough
new for Xbox 360 uh let's fight these
Asians that's
fun some of you think that's racist it's
not if you think about it ninjas Samurai
you fight a lot of
Asians I've been waiting for this one
for a long time Duck Hunt shootable dog
that's yeah finally play dead you
[Applause]
snickering and finally in the Lego
Family of games we got Lego precious
okay yeah based on the book Lego pushed
by Lego
[Applause]
[Music]
Sapphire